a novamente
comecei a trabalhar numa área científica
chamada biologia isso que significa que
significa que o estudo dos animais que
vivem exclusivamente debaixo de terra
sendo que a maior parte dos locais onde
nós nos encontramos são precisamente
grutas existe analogia crerser bias pele
olga
eu aliás a primeira profissão como
lembra de crer ter sido era precisamente
trapezista
por isto é o mais próximo que a
contrapeso na minha profissão que andar
pendurada para encher as profundidade
bom o fato foi a entrada numa gruta as
grutas turísticas do miramar que
disputaram este meu em 3 no mais o time
quando falamos de grupos as pessoas
normalmente têm esta ideia grandes
galerias estou aqui título admite
cristais de grande beleza mas
perguntaram espeleólogo que é uma gruta
provavelmente a sua resposta será algo
como isto são sentidos tratos em leme
atos momentos ian do espanyol que passam
a vida
precisamente a fazer manobras e
artísticas para fugir da água
esta água que promove a formação das
grutas e dos meses calcários o
desenvolvimento dos municípios calcárias
onde existem as grutas que nós
conhecemos como estes aqui próximas da
serra mário candia antes portanto estes
mas esforços grandes manchas de rocha
calcária são a do brado os pressionados
e fraturados por forças forças
tectônicas que abrem espaços entre si
por onde se infiltrar água que vai com
sua ação química e mecânica brindes
passo de cada vez maiores
vai ter ao espaço nós podemos entrar e
progredir e é isto que nós chamamos
gruta gruta é um conceito puramente
antropométrico dimensão que acontece
quando chove muito a superfície nos
presídios calcárias não há água
suficiente toda a água que chega à
superfície do solo enfim
outras circula rapidamente em
profundidade e este subir do nível das
águas que estão grafadas maciço calcário
é muitas vezes extraordinária mente
rápido e provoca a morte que há muitos
espanhóis que estão a exploração nos
rios subterrâneas
não é só a água que forma as grutas e
uma subterrânea também o fogo forma
cavidade de grandes dimensões
algumas delas com mais 100 quilômetros
de desenvolvimento e são os tubos doava
santa uma erupção no vulcão a uma
torrente doava que vê a disputa por uma
pendente e quando se essa erupção e seca
é esse sem fria essa capa que se
solidifica formas um tubo que muitas
vezes podem ter grandes dimensões e tem
mais ou menos este aspeto por dentro e
são as grutas que nós temos nossa equipe
é de da madeira e dos açores bom
independentemente da origem que tenha
uma isso cani ss e calcários e vulcânico
há três condições ambientais que são
extraordinariamente importantes e que
modelam as formas de vida que vive no
seu interior
são elas obviamente ausência de lucho
mas terra não há luz absolutamente
nenhuma
a umidade atmosférica é muito elevada
normalmente 100% quase sempre isto
implica que nós pelos jogos quando
andamos debaixo da terra no momento em
que nos molhamos nunca mais ficamos tão
só sendo a superfície ea temperatura é
constante
para ter uma ideia numa gruta que não é
preciso profunda basta 10 metros de
profundidade durante um ano completo a
amplitude térmica máxima ronda 1° ou
menos
ora nós à superfície numa hora podemos
ter amplitude térmica muito muito
superiores e isto é bom
isto tem consequências óbvias imediatas
nos animais que tem todo seu ciclo de
vida no interior das cavidades então por
um animal conseguir desenvolver
vejo numa idéias deste tipo tem que
desenvolver uma série de adaptações
evolutivas que facilitem a conseguir
viver neste ambiente como como não há
luz
estes animais não precisam de produzir
pigmento para os proteger dos raios
solares
portanto são os pigmentados da mesma
forma também não tem olhos ou têm os
olhos muito reduzidos porque a visão no
escuro é uma é uma função que não que
não é vantajosa e então os seus corpos
modificam se de tal forma e fica tal
forma utilizados que tem patas comprida
centenas compridas uma série de
estruturas sensoriais para se poderem
orientar no escuro e no caso dos insetos
também não tem asas são por isso é que
nós chamamos aptos
estas mudanças nos organismos que vivem
exclusivamente no mais subterrânea não
só do ponto de vista morfológico do
ponto de vista fisiológico estes animais
têm também têm alterações então a
principal delas é que como não há
plantas tanto a luz não há plantas está
em muito pouca energia muito poucos
nutrientes numa subterrânea
então estes animais realizam o seu
metabolismo o máximo que podem estudar
como conseqüência direta o aumento da
longevidade
quando comparados com os seus primos as
superfícies animais vivem mais têm por
isso uma grande resistência jun passam
muitas vezes meses sem conseguir
encontrar alimento tem também
estratégias do ponto de vista produtivo
portanto as fêmeas põem uma menor
quantidade de ovos mais ovos com uma
maior quantidade nutritiva por cada ovo
e tem ainda a ausência do ritmo
circadiano ou seja não são controlados
pela natural cadência da noite dos dias
uma vez que vivem sempre na noite
perpétua
bom a a minha principal área de trabalho
é é um são jonas calcárias do nosso país
portanto aqui em portugal e aqui
apresento vos um bocadinho a evolução do
conhecimento em termos de número de
espécies cavernícolas aqui prefeitamente
adaptadas e o ano em que foram escritas
ou seja descobertas e descritas que
efetivamente passaram existe para a
ciência
isso começou mais ou menos aqui por
volta de meados dos anos 40 e depois
assistimos há quase 60 anos de absoluta
determinação desta área do conhecimento
e como podemos ver a uns anos a esta
parte este número tem vindo a aumentar
consideravelmente
vamos dar um exemplo de um de um animal
que vive nas nas profundidades do nosso
país é um pseudoescorpião especial dos
campeões são predadores de topo tanto
animais que ocupam o topo da cadeia
alimentar nas grutas
estes são dois tamanhos diferentes de 2%
das penas que o pânico mas este
pequenino deve ter cerca de um litro 2
milímetros
o outro já podemos ver que tem mais
peças muito mais alargados portanto um
corpo muito mais adaptado à vida na
profundidade e em 2010 no algarve tico
inscrevemos aquilo que nós chamamos o
pseudo escorpião gigante das grutas do
algarve que é um animal comparativamente
maior do que tudo aquilo que estávamos
habituados a ver isso foi reconhecido
internacionalmente este animal foi
classificado como uma das três espécies
mais fantásticas do nosso planeta
mas a importância de deus animais que o
minicom não é só a sua especto espectro
claridade de forma senão a sua
importância científica
isso não passou desapercebido ao longo
da história da ciência
o próprio darwin quando escreveu a
origem das espécies falou já utilizou os
animais que os únicos como modelo para
explicar uma série de coisas e chamou de
precisamente naufrágio de vida antiga
porque quando olhamos para distribuição
mundial daquela família de
pseudoescorpiões que vos trarei
anteriormente
vemos que sua distribuição mundial e que
o que nós chamamos uma distribuição de
junta ou seja temos dois representantes
na península ibérica e todos os outros
os que estão do outro lado do oceano que
significa significa que estes animais
são tão antigos que já estavam no nosso
território antes da separação dos
continentes a cerca de 160 milhões de
anos e teve vida nas profundezas da
terra
permitiu-nos sobreviver a uma série de
eventos climáticos e das alterações que
assistiram à superfície e caso contrário
não teriam chegado aos nossos tempos
para nos mostrar este registo da
história
o trã outra experiência entretanto o meu
trabalho tem proporcionado foi ter
participado numa expedição à gruta mais
profunda do planeta fica no cáucaso
ocidental muitos de vós já devem ter
estado na nato refere para vos dar uma
idéia do tamanho a gruta mais profundo
do planeta tem mais de 2 quilômetros de
profundidade desde a superfície até o
seu ponto mais profundo e civis mostra
um mapa vertical desta gruta
a torre eifel é qualquer coisa desta
dimensão não é o valor nas grutas
portanto tudo isto é feito por força
humana contra a gravidade quando vamos
para cima para se montar uma expedição
para explorar e para se poder estudar os
animais numa gruta deste estilo é
preciso montar uma exposição com mais 30
pessoas durante cerca de 30 dias em que
tudo mas tudo que nós usamos tem que
subir as montanhas e nós ficamos em
autonomia durante a duração da exposição
para uma inscrição desta magnitude
vários cerca de seis toneladas de
equipamento alimentação e tudo
precisamos para usar lá dentro
este tipo de exploração espeleológica
que nós chamamos as pela elogia alpina
faz em grupo extraordinariamente fria
sobre a questão a grande altitude
a maior parte do ano estas áreas estão
cobertas nervo ea água que escorre no
interior deste grupo provém do dia por
tanque faz as unhas frio lá dentro com
graus e lá de zero em maio até 3 graus
mas sim temperatura e estas posições do
maranhão
o tempo portanto espero jogos para
conseguirem continuar a progredir tem
que montar acampamentos subterrâneas o
que nós chamamos de wax são locais
moderadamente confortáveis onde nós
podemos alimentar nos aquecermos e
dormirmos o antigo moderadamente
confortável
estamos a falar de uma situação em que a
nossa roupa está completamente unida faz
frio satã está completamente úmido
efe as condições de trabalho também não
são melhores nesses ambientes
notamos outra vez a uma temperatura
muito baixa abaixo dos 3 graus
os animais das cavernas sua
extraordinária mente raros de porque em
cima as dimensões difíceis de encontrar
portanto todo este trabalho se faz
nestas condições e este momento o fim de
20 minutos já não há quem consiga
continuar a virar pedras porque o frio é
é um inimigo muito violento mas compensa
e neste caso com pensões largamente
porque nesta cavidade encontramos a
comunidade subterrânea mais profundo do
planeta há mais de dois mil metros de
profundidade tendo em conta que na
altura não se conhecia fauna abaixo dos
1000 metros de profundidade foi de facto
uma surpresa encontrar um show animado
encontramos uma comunidade inteira
composta por predadores por presas uma
estrutura muito interessante bom desde
do trabalho de campo propriamente dito
encontrar os animais trazidos pelo
laboratório é ter a publicação
científica de uma nova espécie por
exemplo já ter de encontrar até que esta
espécie existe a paciência a um trabalho
duro o larguíssimo que demora imenso
tempo e de grande detalhe está por trás
de tudo isto vamos dar um exemplo este é
um bicho enquanto que o veículo
completamente branco e para descrever
uma nova espécie de bicho conta comigo e
nós temos que desenhar estudar em
detalhe todas todas todas as estruturas
que compõem o corpo deste animal fazer
um trabalho comparativo que esse
trabalho vai para uma revista científica
que haja um processo de revisão que seja
aceita que seja publicada
portanto este trabalho que demora algum
tempo
estava interessado em ir às grutas
encontrar animais descrever espécies
novas mães e o que está à porta
para nós não é nosso bem estar e qual a
importância de estudar animais das
cavernas
para além do prazer que são que está
quem faz estes animais estão entre os
mais raros e desconhecidos do nosso
planeta e também de prodígio soja como
conseqüência de serem desconhecidos uma
subterrânea e as grutas em particular
são tal como as ilhas verdade
laboratório de evolução que eu quero
dizer com isto que a simplicidade de
factores ecológicos que nós temos para
analisar nestes maio é muito menor do
que a superfície e nós com muito maior
rapidez com isso conseguimos deduzir
diretamente uma série de resultados das
nossas experiências
depois o custo destes animais também com
contribui por avanços médicos por
exemplo o estudo da regressão ao colar
do gênero que controlam a pressão ocular
e também o estudo das propriedades dos
venenos raros que estes animais têm e
também para navegação aeronáutica por
exemplo é saber como é que os animais
orientou no escuro e tem vindo também a
favorecer o desenvolvimento de novas de
novas naves e de novos aviões comunidade
e principalmente naquilo que nos toca a
nós mais diretamente estes animais têm
um papel fundamental na reciclagem de
matéria orgânica em profundidade porque
isso é importante para nós porque se não
fossem estes animais e degradação da
matéria orgânica que chega aos maiores
reservatórios d'água dos que temos
disponível para o nosso consumo direto
humano nosso planeta que são os macios
calcários nós não temos água de
qualidade e temos que pensar que no
nosso país cerca de 56% d'água que nós
usamos provém de fontes subterrâneas
se nós pensarmos que um mínimo de 60% do
nosso corpo é composto por água fazendo
uma regra de três simples nós
rapidamente chegamos à conclusão que 34%
de nós é água subterrânea como tal
devemos agradecer escolar estes animais
poderão ter água de qualidade para
usarmos no nosso dia a dia
depois por outro lado estava o que está
acumulada nestes reservatórios
subterrâneos invariavelmente chegar à
superfície
nós chamamos as machentes formará fios
esses rios irão dar ao mar e do maridão
evaporaram chover outra vez irá
determinar se o ciclo da água e por fim
o que eu gostava de vos dizer é que têm
corpos gosto casa
cansa muito caso até à exaustão
nós precisamos tanto tempo da nossa vida
a trabalhar
eu acho que compensa fazermos aquilo que
gostamos
ainda que se possa ser
extraordinariamente estranho para a
maioria das pessoas
obrigada